also at the vision 24 National
conservative Forum was Nikki Haley 2024
Republican Presidential wannabe she
didn't make any sense
she actually seems completely unable or
unwilling to explain why she's running
and uh to really uh I mean I don't if
she is auditioning to be Trump's VP that
I understand
if she is auditioning to become the next
Tulsi right who gets a gig on Fox News
and you know a podcast or something then
maybe it makes sense but she seems
visibly confused by every question here
she is saying our kids must say the
Pledge of Allegiance
[Applause]
our kids need to be saying the Pledge of
Allegiance when they start their day so
that they know to love America
[Music]
aha
Nikki Haley who is an advocate of
freedom and liberty
is demanding that children be forced to
recite a pledge of allegiance to the
flag
and that will make them love America
freedom to be forced by schools to say
the Pledge of Allegiance huh it's kind
of kind of interesting doesn't really
make a lot of sense does it uh Nikki
Haley claims that 90 of American
children are now under critical race
Theory they're under it I think she
means under the regime of it or
something listen to this what would you
have to say about the wokism that's
infiltrating the school systems
ninety percent of
our kids
are now under critical race Theory they
used to be over it then they were
alongside it and now they are crushed
beneath its weight that means is if a
little girl goes into kindergarten if
Dad if she's brown or black you're
telling her she's never going to be good
enough and she's always going to be a
victim
[Laughter]
I missed that kindergarten class I would
like to speak to the kindergarten
teacher that is teaching that
and that's wrong the idea that we are
it's also not happening abiding our
children based on race based on religion
based on all of these things that's not
what was supposed to happen you have we
talked about the yeah
I would love for someone to ask Nikki
Haley to Define critical race Theory and
also maybe to Define wokeness what she
says is happening in kindergarten is not
happening period it's just not happening
and she is doing the sort of youngin
thing where she's against woke and she's
against CRT and she wants the pledge
taught oh right but what like what would
be the top tax rate under your
presidency I don't know that's policy I
don't deal with that one more clip from
Nikki Haley's appearance this one is
about parents rights and schools it's
the same nonsense that they're now
obsessing over the problem is these
School bureaucrats have decided parents
can't do their job so they now suddenly
think they have to go and infiltrate
everything that they think should be
taught to our kids we are still the
parents we have to fight for our kids we
have one job and that's to make sure
that we raise our children to be strong
faithful responsible kids and if we
don't stop all this woke ideology that's
happening in our school there it is we
will lose them and we can't afford for
that to happen the biggest critics of SP
of public schools today
have absolutely no idea what is being
taught in public schools they love to
say parents should have the right to
know what their children are being
taught and yet they have no idea what's
going on in public schools by the way
many of them send their kids to private
schools or Charter Schools anyway that's
a different story for a different day
this is what the right is today Tulsi
talking about abortion after birth Nikki
Haley talking about woke and CRT it
draws a crowd it gets Applause and by
the way if you can squeeze in a little
anti-trans rhetoric even more Applause
will anything turn this around to where
the Republican party will get back to
policy that I disagree with but policy
at least uh I don't know I don't know
what if anything will turn this around
but I'll be here waiting and if they
ever want to talk about policy I'm glad
to talk about it with them